Speaker 1: Let's go next to Sabet. So from
Pennsylvania. Or is it Sabato? Subtitle. Save it.
Okay. Welcome.
Speaker 3: Hi.
How are you doing, David?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 6: All right. I think the
only, well, the best chance we have at
at winning the midterms and subsequent elections
is to. You know, the same way that Republicans use
fear. I think we need to use fear as a motivator.
Sadly. And I think we do this by by, you know,
stating that if we don't vote for Democrats, we
are going to be in a right wing dictatorship soon
and start listing. I mean, be more specific
because I think too often we're not specific
enough about what that would look like. You know,
this will be a right wing dictatorship where gay
marriage will be illegal, sweatshops will be
legal, marital rape will become legal. The age
of consent will be lowered. Public schools will
be eliminated. Abortions will become completely
banned. Police will have complete immunity.
Everything will be completely unaffordable.
Journalists will be targeted. And so on and so on.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. I've spoken about this
before. The right the reactionary right
uses fear mongering to win elections,
but they fear monger about imaginary things. So
when we say we on the left need to do a better job
of just telling people what Republicans would
turn the country into, we're not stooping to their
level because these are actually the things that
they want to do. They tell us we want abortion
completely banned. They tell us we need to give
police more immunity. They tell us we want even
lower taxes on the rich. And to overtly create
this over class and not to regulate businesses and
eliminate the Department of Education.
All these different things. If if so, you
only have to listen to them. Whereas the things
they say will happen if Democrats are in power.
They won't actually happen. There will be no more
U.S. border. Of course there will be. Deportations
went up under Obama from where they were under
George W Bush. Of course, there will be a border.
It's going to be communist and socialist. There's
like no communists and socialists in positions of
power in the United States as well, too.
So I am one when I say and when you say
we need to accurately present what an unmitigated
Republican power structure looks like,
we're not using fear in the way they use it. We're
just telling you, here's the things that they want
to do and it absolutely should be done.
Speaker 3: Exactly.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right, my friend Bill,
thank you for the call. Appreciate it.
Yep. All right. There we go. Yeah, it's.
It's scary stuff, guys. It really is.